>> Tucker: MARK ESPER IS A
FORMER DEFENSE LOBBYIST, HE WAS
NOT ELECTED TO THAT POSITION
OBVIOUSLY, WAS APPOINTED TO THE
PRESIDENT WHO WAS HIMSELF
ELECTED.
THAT THE CHAIN OF COMMAND AND
DEMOCRACY.
THEY CHOOSE THEIR
REPRESENTATIVES AND THOSE
REPRESENTATIVES CHOOSE THEIR
STAFF, BUT ALL POWER FLOWS
THROUGH THE PUBLIC TO VOTE IN
ELECTIONS FROM YOU, ME, AND THE
REST OF US.
WHEN CABINET OFFICIALS IGNORE
THE INSTRUCTIONS OF ELECTED
LEADERS, THEY ARE IGNORING
VOTERS IN ATTACKING DEMOCRACY.
IN THE CASE OF THE MILITARY,
IT’S ESPECIALLY DANGEROUS.
ARMED SERVICES ARE CONTROLLED BY
THE PRESIDENT WHO IS ELECTED.
IN MANY COUNTRIES, THAT IS NOT
THE CASE.
WHEN THEY DO SOMETHING THE
MILITARY DOESN’T LIKE, THEY
STAGE A COUP WHERE THEY THREATEN
ONE.
PLACES LIKE THAT INVARIABLY ARE
VIOLENT AND CHRONICALLY UNSTABLE
UNSTABLE.
WE DON’T WANT TO BE LIKE THAT.
WE CAN GIVE OUR NUCLEAR WEAPONS
TO THE MILITARY ON THE PROMISE
THAT WE ARE ESSENTIALLY IN
CHARGE WHEN THEY USE THEM
BECAUSE WE ELECT A PRESIDENT TO
THAT CALL.
HE PROBABLY KNEW ALL THAT.
IT’S BASIC CIVICS FOR IT WAS
UNTIL DONALD TRUMP.
RECENTLY, THE PRESIDENT
SUGGESTED HE MIGHT INVOKE THE
INSURRECTION ACT THAT WOULD
ALLOW HIM TO USE AMERICAN TROOPS
TO QUELL THE RIOTS IN OUR
CITIES.
THAT IS HIS CALL.
YOU CAN AGREE WITH IT OR NOT,
BUT HE’S THE PRESIDENT.
IT’S UP TO HIM.
IS NOT UP TO MARK ESPER.
MARK ESPER DOESN’T LIKE IT, HE
CAN RESIGN AND VOTE AGAINST
DONALD TRUMP IN THE FALL AND MAY
DO THAT ANYWAY.
WHAT HE CAN’T DO, BUT WE CANNOT
LET HIM DO IF WE CARE ABOUT
DEMOCRACY IS TO SUBVERT THE
ORDER OF THE PRESIDENT HE WORKS
FOR NO MATTER WHO THE PRESIDENT
IS.
AND YET, YESTERDAY, HE APPEARED
TO DO EXACTLY THAT.
HE GAVE A PRESS CONFERENCE IN
WHICH HE ANNOUNCED THAT HE
OPPOSES USING TROOPS TO BRING
ORDER TO THE COUNTRY.
AMERICAN TROOPS IN SYRIA AND
AFGHANISTAN ARE ABSOLUTELY
NECESSARY.
WE CAN’T PULL THEM OUT.
IT’S A IMMORAL.
THAT IS MARK ESPER’S POSITION.
APPARENTLY, HE SAID THIS AT THE
URGING OF ACTIVE-DUTY GENERALS
AT THE PENTAGON.
NOW, ONCE AGAIN, IT DOESN’T
MATTER WHETHER YOU AGREE WITH
THEIR POSITION.
THIS KIND OF BEHAVIOR IS A GRAVE
THREAT TO ALL OF US AND TO OUR
CONSTITUTIONAL SYSTEM.
AND THAT SYSTEM IS TEETERING
TONIGHT.
BUT SOME IN WASHINGTON WOULD
LIKE TO SEE THE SYSTEM COLLAPSED
COMPLETELY.
JUST SEND THE CHAIRMAN OF JOYCE
JOE MIKE JOINT CHIEFS OF STAFF
TELLING HIM TO DENY THE ELECTED
PRESIDENT IN ORDER TO SUPPRESS
THE RIOT.
IT CAN’T LEAD ANYWHERE GOOD.
FOR 230 YEARS, WE HAVE BEEN THE
BENEFICIARIES OF CIVILIAN
CONTROL OF THE MILITARY.
ONE OF THE MAIN REASONS THIS
COUNTRY HAS ALWAYS BEEN STABLE.
BUT WHEN THE MILITARY BECOMES AN
INDEPENDENT POLITICAL FORCE,
IT’S OVER.
DEMOCRACY DIES.
WE RESISTED THAT MANY TIMES JUST
FOR THE SECOND WORLD WAR.
HELPING JOSEPH STALIN, THEY
DIDN’T WANT TO DO THAT.
THEY UNDERSTAND THE MORAL THREAT
OF COMMUNISM BUT THEY WERE TOLD
TO DO IT, AND THEY DID IT
BECAUSE THAT IS OUR SYSTEM.
IS DEMOCRACY.
IN THAT SYSTEM HAS WORKED VERY
WELL FOR A LONG TIME.
IN FACT, IT’S WHY WE WERE HERE
ON MILITARY.
BECAUSE WE CAN.
THEY ARE NOT PART OF OUR
POLITICAL SYSTEMS.
THEIR ONLY JOB IS TO PROTECT THE
COUNTRY, AND THEY DO.
BUT IF PEOPLE LIKE MARK ESPER
CONTINUE ON THIS PATH, WE WILL
NOT LIKE OUR MILITARY AT ALL.
WE WILL BE VERY AFRAID OF THEM,
AND WE DON’T WANT TO BE.
BY INDEED RIGHT AS A DEMOCRAT,
FORMER CIA OFFICER AND HAPPY TO
HAVE HIM TONIGHT.
THANK YOU SO MUCH FOR COMING ON.
I’M NOT GOING TO ASK YOU WHAT
YOU THINK OF THE PRESIDENT’S
IDEA TO INVOKE THE INSURRECTION
ACT TO PUT TROOPS ON THE STREETS
STREETS.
YOU SERVED IN GOVERNMENT,
BUREAUCRATS DECIDE UNILATERALLY
TO MAKE POLICY.
>> THAT’S WHAT WE’VE SEEN THE
PAST THREE YEARS, IS IN IT?
ALL OF THAT IS COMING OUT.
THAT’S A NEW PHENOMENON OF
COURSE.
A HORRIFYING ONE, BUT NOT NEW.
WHAT WE HAVE HERE I THINK OF
MORE SPECIFICALLY IS A SECRETARY
OF DEFENSE WHO DOESN’T GET IT.
RIGHT NOW, LET’S JUST CUT TO THE
CHASE.
THIS COUNTRY IS ON FIRE.
WE ARE FACING AN INSURRECTION BY
PEOPLE THAT WE DON’T QUITE
UNDERSTAND WHO THEY ARE AND BY
ALL INDICATIONS, THEY ARE
VIBRANTVIOLENT TO LEFTIST BUGS.
WHAT THEY DON’T SEEM TO GET AS A
NATION IS PANICKING.
71% OF US WANT THEM THERE
TONIGHT.
8% OF US WANT THE MILITARY IN
OUR CITIES TONIGHT.
THE PEOPLE ARE PANICKING.
THE COUNTRY IS ON FIRE.
NOW, WHO IS ATTACKING US?
MR. ESPER SHOULD KNOW THIS.
IS ANTI-FOR, DEPARTMENT OF
JUSTICE, DEPARTMENT OF JUSTICE,
NYPD, OTHERS ARE SAYING THIS
VERY CLEARLY.
THESE ARE PEOPLE WHO ARE FAR
LEFTIST, FOLKS WHO HAVE EMBRACED
THAT IDEOLOGY.
THEY’VE ALLIED BLACK PANTHER
MOVEMENT AND IT TAKES MANY YEARS
TO FINALLY PUT IT DOWN.
VERY DANGEROUS.
AND NOW THE SAME GROUP WHO IS
ALLIED WITH THE DEMOCRATIC
SOCIALIST, THEY ARE BACK.
THEY ARE BACK WITH FIREBOMBS AND
SUBURBS AND THE DOWNTOWNS.
THAT IS SOMETHING THEY CLEARLY
DON’T UNDERSTAND.
THEN WE HAVE A MEDIA THAT IS
FEEDING THIS FLAME, THIS
SEDITIOUS NOTICE.
YOU HAVE BROUGHT THIS UP MANY
TIMES INCLUDING TONIGHT.
LET ME READ A HEADLINE FROM
SLATE MAGAZINE JUST YESTERDAY,
SAID THE FOLLOWING.
PEACEFUL PROTESTS ARE IMPORTANT
TOOL, BUT SO IS VIOLENCE.
SO NOW WE HAVE MEDIA FILLING THE
AIRWAYS FULL OF THIS.
PUT IT ALL TOGETHER, AND THE
PEACE THAT YOU MENTIONED, CAN’T
PUT FORWARD THE NATIONAL GUARD
BECAUSE OF THE DE-ESCALATION SO
THEN YOU TAKE OFF THE MILITARY
FROM THE TABLE.
WHERE DOES THAT LEAVE?
LET ME TELL YOU WHAT IT LEAVES.
VIGILANTE JUSTICE.
EVERYBODY WATCHING THIS PROGRAM
ARMING OURSELVES.
IS THAT HOW WE RUN A REPUBLIC?
NO, IT IS NOT.
YOU DO NOT WANT A COUNTRY THAT
GOES THERE.
THAT IS PRECISELY WITH THE
NATION IS HEADED AND WE NEED FOR
ALL OF OUR LEADERSHIP TO
UNDERSTAND THIS.
IF HE DOESN’T GET IT, DOESN’T
UNDERSTAND IT IS TO PROTECT
OURSELVES FROM THREATS BOTH
FOREIGN AND DOMESTIC THEN GET
OUT OF THE PENTAGON AND LET
SOMEBODY LEAD WHO GETS IT
BECAUSE THAT IS THE OATH THAT HE
TOOK, THAT I TOOK, AND THE
PEOPLE OF THIS COUNTRY DEMANDED
BY LEADERSHIP BECAUSE WE ARE ON
FIRE.
SOMEONE DO SOMETHING ABOUT IT.
>> Tucker: I COULDN’T AGREE
MORE.
JUST HAVE TO WONDER WHY PEOPLE
ARE ENCOURAGING THIS.
REALLY SHOULD MEDITATE ON THAT.